if you're only sort of like goal is to
be liked then you can sort of compromise
yourself
um your morals your work your
relationships so I'm looking at the
camera
um I mean I think the person I had the
best rapport with was Sam Rockwell we
did everything together we I'm pretty
sure we had scenes where we would have
to like finish each other's sentences so
we kind of became like
a weird set of twins almost probably
when I'm working when I'm
not completely messing something up I
think it's a wonderful feeling to be on
stage
and kind of feel like you've got some
sort of control over what you're doing
because that's such a terrifying
environment to be in especially if you
don't do it all the time and I don't
I've only done it a handful of times so
when I feel confident in that
environment I definitely feel like I'm
flying I think I've been relatively
fortunate in my experiences as an actor
I you know yes I've worked with people
who are a bit more difficult as people
do in every industry
um and actually because I had my mother
with me till I was about 18 and I had
sort of a good strong Foundation to deal
with that whenever it came my way and
sort of knew what was right and what was
okay in terms of like etiquette and
behavior on sets whether it was by
someone else or by me production
companies like lucky chap from Argos
production company is do doing such a
great job at focusing on sort of female
impaired movies but also just making
really really great work and I think
that that's very inspiring for other men
and women in the industry there's
certain departments on our set that are
definitely more kind of male dominated
but there's definitely
so many improvements being made
certainly the great filmmakers that I
work with not everyone but the ones that
I've worked with for the most part want
everyone to sort of have their time in
the song so yeah when I'm with the
people that I'm closest to is when I
feel most like myself when I'm with my
dog because she doesn't I was going to
say she doesn't judge me but actually
she probably does judge me a bit and she
does a lot of side eye quite a lot of
the time when we're together but um I
still love her anyway when I'm doing
stuff like cold water swimming and sort
of just like being in the elements I
think you're forced to completely adapt
to that and survive it and like embrace
it so only the the real you comes out in
those kind of situations I feel I guess
respected if you're only sort of like
goal is to be
liked then you can sort of compromise
yourself
um your morals your work your
relationships so yeah I think ultimately
it's more important to be respected but
also to be nice to people if I was in a
murder mystery
what would I be in real life I don't
think I would be the one solving it I'm
not gonna lie and I've done a few Escape
rooms and I've gotten better but like
initially I just sort of panic and like
organize things because I don't know
what else to do I could just be like a
bystander could just be just like you
know an on Locker
I could do the whole like I think he
went that way
I think I'd probably be someone like
that
I don't think I'd be the victim because
I do think that I'm
very suspicious naturally so I think I'd
get away from the murderer because I'm
always kind of on guard anyway social
media can be a terrific tool for other
people who use it in a sort of moderate
and healthy way I mean I've just been to
my best friend's wedding and it was an
excellent source of workouts planning
wedding dress styles you know things
that it can be it can be a great source
of all of those things but for me to be
honest I wasn't really getting anything
out of it I guess I don't want people I
don't know to have access to
my life I mean I wasn't really in the
public eye from nine I wasn't doing
projects that focused on children or a
younger demographic and I think that's
when you really get like serious instant
Fame you know yeah it's a it's a weird
thing to be
recognized by people but pretty much all
the time it's positive and
supportive it's depressing but this is
all I've ever done so I don't know what
I would do although I've always loved
the radio and certainly through
promoting movies
um I've spent a lot of time at different
radio stations and with different
presenters and things like that and I've
always really loved that I love the buzz
of it like go and see like Zoe ball and
stuff and she's like running around her
Studio flicking buttons and you know
bringing people in and doing great
interviews and playing great music and
nobody sees her that seems ideal to me
so yeah I'd quite like to do something
like that
um or something that involved eating
Maybe
that'd be fun cold water is great for
your mental health so cold chairs in the
morning are great jumping into the sea
is great music really helps me honestly
um I'll go in and out of doing
meditation and things like that but
um yeah I'm very lucky I've got
wonderful people that I can speak here I
also just like being on my own and I
think that can be really helpful too to
just have some time to yourself and
actually having an animal around is uh
just a wonderful addition to your life
and it gives you something else to focus
on that isn't you so I was trying to
figure out whether I should do this job
that had been offered to me and on paper
it was something that I absolutely
should do and I'd be an idiot to turn it
down but for a number of reasons it
stressed me out the idea of doing a
brilliant director who I made Brooklyn
with John Crowley he said to me that you
have to protect your bond with your work
that it's sort of like its own little
separate thing it's separate from you
and it's separate from the kind of final
project and it's the relationship that
you know in any industry that you have
with your work and you have to look
after that and you have to take care of
it and respect it and he said only ever
do the things that
um you want or you need to do don't do
the things that you should do so I've
always kept that in my head ever since
he said it